bonsoir d'une émission spéciale oui la
musique dans ce culture première du
jeudi 28 juin le peintre le plasticien
de photographes a disparu brutalement
vendredi dernier dans son domicile
familial de la plaine des palmistes
nous allons évoquer avec eux nos invités
celui qui a été un oncle compagnon un
ami ou un confidente dans notre studio
florence site sa nièce entonne duvignau
artistes perdre et un ami un autre très
proche du rouillât mme dit jean-claude
carpanin marimoutou et patricia de
bolivia directrice de l'école supérieure
d'art de la réunion la réalisation
sonore est assurée par baboo ce soir
[Musique]
bien bonsoir à tous merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation va ce soir
parler de l'artiste du militant de
l'homme d'un ami du caf site vous l'avez
connu tous à différents titres nous
avons une quarantaine de minutes pour
parler de cet homme de 63 ans
parti il ya presque une semaine
personnage un homme au franc parler un
homme de conviction il est mort dans sa
dernière maison là où est la plaine des
palmistes mais on oublie qu'il a vécu
longtemps saint leu et là où il a
commencé à créer saint leu et
trois-bassins là où il a commencé à
travailler comme instituteur laurent
zitte bonsoir vous êtes sa nièce et un
moment de sa vie où il est allé faire sa
scolarité en france où et pendant
combien de temps alors c'est exact il a
été chez jésuites pardon très tôt vers
ses 10 ans et
il a été accompagné par mes grands
parents et ses frères également pour
poursuivre ses études
les idoles région vous savez alors à là
je vais des défauts est plutôt bon alors
est ce que quelqu'un automne à table
c'est où il a fait ses sa part été
entendus vignes rapprochez vous du micro
antoine oui bonsoir oui je crois que
c'est dans la drôme alex alex bon ben ok
d'accord donc les grands parents sont
partis étaient là bas et je crois que
c'est c'la là-bas au contact des
jésuites m'arrêter ainsi je dis des
bêtises au contact des jésuites qui l'a
fait connaissance enfin tous les cas
avec l'art c'est bien cela qui répond à
l'est antoine est une lourde
oui me semble il me semble que c'est là
qu'il a été en contact avec toute
l'iconographie chrétienne relieuses ah
oui il a beaucoup après site et
réemployés il a rendu hommage si jamais
renier renier au travail retravailler
[Musique]
avec la dollée d'école en école primaire
ou bien d'accord et donc lutter l'école
ensemble et depuis l'école dite
intéressée yassa les plus connectés
l'école primaire bankole des synthés
fait 7e ça et en plus c'est bon l'été
rappelle benni t il les a rendus à la
messe et ça va à l'église commence
toujours comme ça et puis est donc un
titre tout s'attendre à ce que sa base
et racontera déjà avant évidemment utile
et imagine pas un joueur fait d'accord à
ce que voudront se racheter quelque
chose ou pas par rapport à cette
question sur son début n'ont pas fait
symbolique est ce qui vous a fait des
confidences là-dessus non vos de
l'enfance en tout cas sur son début de
sa création sous de son processus de
création
non en fait plutôt sur justement le
processus de création mais pas forcément
sur l'historique mais effectivement à
quel point ça allait accompagner y
compris en tant qu'instituteur dans le
travail avec les enfants et commence
étaient présents dans tout son toute son
activité en fait alors ça il a aimé ça
avec rail et des enfants émilie là il a
pris jadis un peu n'importe quoi pour
pouvoir faire aimer l'art aux enfants
qui répond vous battez pas non non non
je l' ai connu l'été encore vous avez
connu quand toi au 89 89 c'est l'orangé
gaitan qui s'appelait l'époque péter
rose qui me l'avait fait rencontrer et
il était enseignant abraham août au
moment où il était passionné par sa
soeur s'est excusé et je me rappelle
l'avoir vu diriger pour la fin d'année
une chorale et tous en costume ça serait
marrant d'entendre dire ça parce que je
m'imagine pas du tout en costume mais
oui portait pas très bien quoi
en tout cas mais il avait réellement un
magnétisme avec les enfants qui étaient
absolument ahurissant - moi mes enfants
mes neveux et tout ça dès qu'il le
voyait c'était pouvait plus parler à
quand on avait des réunions de travail
un peu il passait son temps avec les
gosses et puis moi j'étais là et lui qui
n'a jamais eu de gosses sont plus assez
marrant ça de me mettre fin ce
magnétisme pour reprendre le mot qu'il
avait avec des enfants alors quand on a
peut-être il peut déjà veiller au bon
moment surtout quand tu es sahel oui
parce que là aussi
oui bonne forme mais pas vraiment et les
l'école même l'avait bombe allemande a
été bien là la plage du petit garçon au
cas où il y avait un espèce de relation
une bonne note est vraiment vraiment
gaillacois et l'été il était papa bana
pour marmailles et ses salles étaient
intéressants étaient colonna sur les
trucs pareils quoi cela rassure le
création l'écriture de facom sa tante
ont effectivement la relation avec les
enfants
de la famille puis mam et autres ils
nous disaient toujours des bêtises la
salle i fé laisse je me suis obligé les
gagne pas du tout au tout et on avait
dit il mérite ce reality game pas dit
non et alors je disais que bon état il
avait comme une maison donc à saleux qui
était pour moi un fouillis parce qu'il
veut de tous deux dans cette maison n
était même pas n'était pas tes cousins
la ferrade à des mets pas tes tous et
des pâtes et une étoile et des
paralysies j'allais droit touché et est
une oeuvre d'art voilà alors qu'ils ont
bon je pense que tous vous avez connu
cette maison à saint leu alors comment
vous la voyez vous se l'était fait une
alliée d'accord non comme mango est ce
que la réalité est là dans un salon dans
cette case à dire quelque chose qui
inspira les gaver de thoune avait des
piles on l'avait plein ça fait dans les
tuyaux
oui mais qui collectionnait il avait
besoin de s'entourer de pleins d'objets
qui qui l'inspirait piste et une casque
était ouverte
pouvait départ jusqu'à 6 tonnes soit
c'est un william te faire la peau
penser que d'été où vient il faisait en
fait sauf sauf que parfois je vais la
faire tomber sauf comme ça quand ses
prix bas le coup bien manger dehors avec
françois élie et mais sinon ça caille et
la bête nathan williams en quarts sont
prévalus pas qu'il fait mais c'était
bonnes vielles d'halong est rentrée mais
sinon c'était à refaire il d'accord ok
alors il ya mon cas ça l'a commencé ce
matin d'hier
cette envie de mettre des cas de panne
le caf
il est quoi il l'est n'est venu comment
cette envie alors
une personne qui l'a inspiré il
s'appelle michel
on a eu l'occasion de le rencontrer
le samedi et ça m'a fait vraiment ça m'a
touché de le voir toujours d'enterrement
ça oui d'autant de l'enterrer
effectivement de voir la personne qui
l'a inspiré et les jean-michel
jean-michel oui c'est ça et franchement
je on souhaite la famille garder contact
avec lui parce que il représente
beaucoup pour nous d'accord vous alors
vous avez connu jean michel aulas à tous
autour de la table
oui oui je m'attends pas non plus voilà
donc huit tombes
oui vise les revues quand j'allais voir
à la plaine williams à la moi je me
souviens de sa le mois à assat le oui vu
que c'est bien moi je pense de
jean-michel box alors une des filles de
jean michel et la fiole la vielle de
temps où il ya mais il s'en occupait son
enfant il était très soucieux très
pointilleux un bon parent un vrai
parrain d'accord justement il vous me
disiez florence qui ne paie pas
compliquer une fiole il en avait
plusieurs analystes y accole 3 c'est ça
oui et s'en occuper autant que ses
filles elle est fille elle papillonne il
s'en occuper un que soient nos enfants
de
deux frères et soeurs de toute la
famille c'était comme s'ils s'étaient
ses enfants en fait donc
la niveau là je pense qu'il a il a été
un bon excusez moi j'arrive pas à parler
à vous passer il est un bon parent donc
[Musique]
alors vouloir vouloir mettre vouloir
mettre une tête de cas c'était allégeant
parlement les révolutionnaires non parce
que je l'avais je n'avais jamais fait ça
date de l'époque c'est un peu près ça
c'est bien les années 90 en fait on a
vraiment on assiste à une espèce de
commandes ird émergents sont faites et
de prise de conscience qui avait été
déjà présente un dans la littérature je
pense que carpanin peux confirmer c'est
vrai dans les arts plastiques
déjà la fin des années 80 il ya des
expositions comme les arts déchaîné une
espèce de volonté s'approprier
l'histoire et de parler d'un de tout un
pan qui était un peu restée dans l'ombre
jusqu'à présent donc laisser de rompre
avec l'image un peu doudou east de la
culture réunionnaise et une volonté de
dire aussi comment dire une certaine
qu'une certaine culture qui jusqu'à
présent était un peu minier alors
cessons archéologie c'est ça c'est ça il
ya une exposition qui était fondatrice
il me semblait donc peut-être que vous
allez renchérir c'est l'exposition qui
s'appelait c'est en 92 cents obscur
chambre noire chant obscur et qui
montrait des photographies
anthropométriques de désir et scharner
qui a été prise en 1863 et qui montrait
les esclaves
de face de dos donc c'était vraiment une
vision scientifique est très très
objectivante et justement c'est ça toute
la question en fait de montrer des des
personnes en tant qu'objet et tout le
projet de zita était justement de les
montrer en tant que sujet d'en faire des
sujets d'en faire des gens qui regardent
et donc de les représenter
voilà en tant que sujets non plus en
tant qu'objet antoine non j'écoute
patricia mais qu'un bon vieux d'état
écoutez vous êtes là pour en parler
donc si vous vous taisez parce que en
fait jusqu'à présent pas pour reprendre
l'expression d'une vision un peu d'eau
douce du noir au loin un autre cadre est
celui qu'on voit en bas côté du dieu du
côlon henri iv bon voilà y'a bon
peut permettre à moi c'est bien
sûr un windows étant maintenant avanzit
médias à william était moins de drizzt
méprisant
voir les images de dominer le mans
s'était soldée nénène des choses coûteux
et les vrais que le
le rembourrage obscures avec les photos
de charme next media pas des esclaves et
engagés et que les poteaux entre
métriques en toc aux métriques bébés qui
ont été transformés en objets mais les
termes même temps très très très très
méprisant 3 elle avait ça et puis il
avait évidemment tout le mouvement black
américain autour de black ce que tu fous
d'où le café sveti foule voilà williams
voilà et donc la baie la victoire est
tout ce mouvement là et donc quoique ce
que cela déclenche une affaire c'était
de munte cause ban de montescot sicaf
mais 24 cause pas s'il a changé ça vous
trouve à changer quand même depuis et
donc lavées soon as fait et cause d'eux
mais voilà et est donc avec le respect
de 10 kw h soit plombant que les
politiques où nous luttons culturelle
extérieure de cette génération là et le
propos de deux hits c'était de montrer
qu aucun cas flammes en commun note et
même ailier joly il faut pas avoir honte
de ça et lille est une oeuvre d'art en
tant que tel et et donc du coup il a
fait intéressant par rapport au discours
un peu humiliant mais errabie liste et
victimaire sur le caf c'était de montrer
que ballack a été un sujet un sujet
agissant un sujet peu avec que ce bang
appelle la jane s'il a une puissance
d'agir et l et voilà que les tpe
occupent l'espace le prochain grand
rupture que william y apporte c'est pas
tellement les opérateurs du câble être
autrement du caf en tant que sujet dit
bonsoir dominique louis clar jeunes à
nous entre temps dont nous parlait donc
du café dont de la vision que vous il y
en a voulu donner à sur le cafard la
société réunionnaise et que les
commandes comme des carpes à des
ruptures ou pata cher dominique c'est un
travail assez extraordinaire qu'il a
fait à la fois plastiquement mais qu'il
a fait également dans son engagement
personnel parce que il ya aussi tout le
côté où william a accompagné portée des
démarches et accompagner des artistes
pendant longtemps à une émergence et
notamment le bond caf et pas que des cas
parce que
enfin seulement les artistes nous aussi
il nous a énormément nous ont pris nos
amis famille
il a fait des recherches on sait nos
origines descendants d'esclaves voilà
qu'on ait des descendants d'esclaves de
ba dinh
on a eu également dans la famille
décapiter un voleur qui a été décapité
la vie après il nous a toujours enfin
moi il m'a toujours un peu mon cas tu es
en disant arrête mettre la chaîne
d'autres pieds arrête mettre la chaîne
d'hôtes dans le bras ou les parias les
esclaves ou la casse à celle là et je
pense que c'était pour l'ensemble des
personnes qui ont pu vraiment le côtoyer
où il disait selon de choses parce que
il tenait tellement à tout ça que i à
nous transmettre ce savoir est bon après
nous chacun a pu prendre une partie
presque tout faux c'est surtout fort
qu'on dise à la famille parce que oui on
vient après celle qui entend et entend
séduire autant pas longtemps alors tout
le monde mais suppose que la famille
écouta soit je pense qu'on perd bon ok
bon enfin bref l écoute alors justement
pour parler on parle d' esclavage mais
il ya un moment il a fait une exposition
ville elle qui a choqué alors qu'on se
raconte à nous raconter ça c'était
n'exploite duvignau me croise temps en
92 en fait quand est à fond d'une malle
elle chante daniel que daniel a chanté
d'ailleurs ça me dit oui bon train la
caméra ne sais pas ce que tu en avant va
voir avec cet abri oui mais n'est pas
grave antoine va voir quand même bon
maître droite
alors donc il paraît que la ville a
choqué la baisse était dans la maison
non mais justement est pourquoi il a
choqué il faut dire pourquoi détail
quelque chose qui la fait que alors
antoine raconte à oui je vais raconter
les petites histoires
c'était sûr effectivement l'image du
noir et donc on avait investi non
seulement le bâtiment l'ancien hôpital
des esclaves et les friches aussi donc
c'était quand même un gros travail ce
qui était assez novateur à l'époque de
de proposer de l'art aussi bien dans un
lieu consacré quand en extérieur et
effectivement il ya une salle de
l'ancien hôpital où on avait fait un
triptyque il y avait une autre salle où
il y avait une pietà il y avait un
triptyque avec la toile du milieu une
reproduction enfin à sa manière d'un
mercenaire
comment rien donc c'était une image du
noir avec une mitraillette un béret tsé
tsé et le conservateur de l'époque le
seul à sankara d'ailleurs son jean
barbier a demandé que ce soit retirée il
estimait que c'était trop trop brutaux
view trop violent je sais pas c'était un
peu surprenant et donc on a été obligés
de
retirer la toile on s'est demandé avec
will i am si on annulait pas ces
thérapies finalement s'est dit encore on
garde a d'autant plus que daniel avait
fait un morceau qui s'appelle fête kaf
exprès pour cette expo et c'était la
première fois où daniel a accepté de
venir à villèle dominique nouvelle et je
disais quand en même temps c'est assez
emblématique de william et de sa formule
je me suis toujours construit sur la
dissidence et la polémique il était dit
en créole
mais bon mes petits micros pas stabilité
m quand on doit faire en sorte de monde
y réagit et donc été cool it est un peu
couillon
ben justement mais quand il est lié
aussi aider ça mais croit le travail
statkraft royce ghost rider est liée
aussi à tout son travail sur la culture
populaire et s'il fait de -10 cause
domoni dit de monde n'a pas honte de
monde
les fiancés de télé et ça et ça l'ailier
il avait pas eu de recours cette
exposition une galerie de magie du
quelque part a gelé pas vu l'exposition
y sommes une espèce de galerie de
portraits donc de noir qui faisait face
aux galeries delà des familles blanches
qui avait dans un avis dont vous savez
un peu
non c'est pas évident non mais c'était
quand même toute une série qui était
fait d'après en retraite des iris à
[Musique]
charmey sur des gones il va donc on va
vraiment parler des gones est justement
mais tout endroit paisible où il voudra
acheter quelque chose ou pas n'ont pas
un moment effectivement de l'aspect
williams à animateur de radio justement
cette capacité d'amener les gens à aller
plus loin et avoir parfois des émissions
il ya des des auditeurs qui nous ont
confié avoir écouté l'émission parce
qu'ils attendaient le moment on ne les
souhaite sur la gueule parce qu'on avait
créé un jeu qui était à la limite de la
polémique où on était des fois vraiment
d'ailleurs vraiment pas d'accord et se
modérait pas dans les propos mais
parfois on poussait les choses un peu
plus loin ce qu'a mené nos invités dans
ce jeu là aussi et il ya des gens qui
prenaient soin au premier degré à leyton
époque là n'avait pas apprécié je me
sens même de rap à talas qui avait fait
arrêter l'émission il avait il n'avait
pas arrêté l'émission qui est intervenu
sur un titre v6 et un contexte un peu
particulier
d'accord ok alors leygonie on va en
parler des votes lui non si je peux me
permettre
la bd on sait assez pensé plutôt bien
entendu parce qu'on avait aussi des
références artistiques commune entre
autres il aimait beaucoup le travail des
menus ou un rôle et de matisse quand on
connaît la danse de matisse et qu'on
veut voir les personnages et mathis a
écrit à écrire des petits extraits de
livres et dans un de ses livres
mathis dit le noir est la couleur de la
lumière est alors le jour on a découvert
ça a été j'ai été enchantée c'était une
très belle image alors pour les gens qui
ne voient pas enfin qui nous coûte aux
canadiens on va dire que quand on dit
vigneault et blanc donc date où le
mandat ni l'aura rouge de blanc prouvent
ses yeux bleus et blancs aux yeux bleus
web alors des gones et on va parler des
gones ils ont fait une pause musicale
qu'est ce que vous ferez on enchaîne il
veut la poste alors on va demander
justement fait la pause musicale là une
chanson qui a été choisi par anton
duvignau donc on va l'écouter mon coco
petit extrait assez court parce qu'il
faut composer un discuter maintenant
débat vous n'auriez le premier morceau
qui sur la liste dans la pile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
côté la grosse virginia des grands comme
l atteinte ya six mois je crois mais
quand y'a l'époque boutade
à noter la grosse des gignac en moins le
petit copain m'a déjà tout acquis tout
cas qu'elle a passée gros comme ça
et pourtant doctel à diaby
pas moi j'aime mon pays
tension va monter temps plein pas
montrée prudente et soigne accueillis
tous les jours mais les dégâts tout
oui moi
c'est un vtt à la danse virginie a
chanté par la tentation c'est en tant
que tel à choisir donne beaucoup de
choses y sont ceux-là parce que william
avait des très bons goûts musicaux il
s'était occupé d'une radio une petite
radio de trois bassins de vie non non
c'est être une radio dans les collèges
jean michel fontaine doit commencer
jean-michel oui peut-être d'accord radio
medi est donc on partageait beaucoup de
proximité en musique mais la chanson
qu'il adorait à chaque fois c'était la
grosse virginia pourquoi la france à
s'expliquer c'est comme ça voilà a fait
alors là on va parler donc des gones est
à ma connaissance vous m'arrêtez sujet
des bêtises c'est bien la première fois
qu'on voyait quelqu'un peine sera connue
non pas partie ça mais à ma connaissance
ceci antoine je sais pas moi ceci
toujours gêné de prétendre que c'est la
première fois qu'un arc en tous les cas
la réunion à la réunion oui je pense oui
le coroner avant la limite et pen somony
la réunion tout cas la ligue a fait des
émules après un oui mais qu'au niveau
n'a pas non mais t'as nous pourquoi
toile deux hits
je pense ici à cognac justement toile de
zigic toile déido dans les émules et
jean-bernard rondeurs et a manqué repris
tout ça avec l'art postal et qui a
repris les sacs postaux et qui est en
même temps vers un rondin développer ça
mais avec une autre approche et pour
peindre agonie je vous raconte
oui il faut pas une deux fois deux fois
dix fois vingt fois nous on le disait
avec williams à la palette conduit toute
la peinture
il est 18 heures 48 quand même lancé un
appel parce que je pense qu'ils nous
écoutent ça va a été convenu comme ça
jean-michel hérode qui est à l' écoute
on devait appeler on devenait alors on
va de se parler donc ce soir au
téléphone en jean michel lesage appelle
un hôpital à la au téléphone n'arrive
pas à avoir à eau mais je n'ai pas
pourquoi alors s'il vous plaît des blocs
de téléphone comme ça doit bien causer
merci beaucoup à faire plaisir à moi
fait appeler un bon peu de monde autour
de la table
merci jean michel aulas jean michel
c'est donc la tête de caf que william
donc la reproduit en milliers de fois
donc et qui retrouve un peu partout pour
les gens qui avaient fait des
autocollants maria de plus il ya de bus
lui en effet associant les tiges faire
alors et montrer qu est ce que vous avez
fait aussi d'un lasse lascaux menacée
c'est pas des têtes de caf
ben voilà c'est ça la chemise mais
c'était pour l'expo ça allait mieux
après ça c'est local ou valve
il avait le souci de trouver plein de 2
d'interprétation d'un de ces travail
c'est à dire il était dans la série
aussi c'est pour ça que le travail
d'andy warhol lui plaisait alors me
montre donc la photo donc une photo que
vous auront saisi de la maine coon une
photo pour tacna l'occasion des
sonnettes anne est donc une photo donc
de jean-michel jeune grand et reconnaît
jean-michel y avait à peu près comme il
en avait 18 ans quand on a produit
j'étais très jeune maraîcher sa nuit
voilà alors voilà c'est nul n'a pas là
donc là on a des photos là bas merci
florence est donc jean-michel est
devenue célèbre comme ça malgré lui ou
au contraire avait en toute connaissance
de cause e
sur quoi les la peine jean michel
illégaux ni du dépôt choix la ville dans
le paysage en fait il a marqué un peu le
territoire avec salle uniquement l'avait
aussi bas si de plus sur les journaux un
papier l'aï trouvé bien il dessinait sur
un papier et a pris des signes pas
seulement au crayon il prenait son cash
veille à la main il dessinait passe à la
plupart ça c'est avec du café ça yaourt
ou si oui on sait sa droite dans le
premier article 0 ça avait fait ces deux
pages me rappelle très très bien il le
mentionnait nous pour se moquer de lui
on le disait alors telle artiste au
yaourt
c'était une volonté d'utiliser des
matériaux vraiment pauvre été simple
pour tout le monde puisque rupture aussi
avec l'idée de beaux-arts la peinture à
l'huile sur une toile à prêter là
c'était des toiles du site du papier et
puis des matériaux très facilement
utilisable et matériaux pauvres
ouais c'est ça n'est pas bien bataillé
mais elle était recommandé que ça à la
disposition des trois oppositions loi et
la réalité populaire et voilà la réalité
populaire c'est pas pour rien n'a été
détectée à tout à fait des expositions
je te moto de céréales populaire et et
liteo revendique sa la pauvre la brute
de la bern acculèrent annonçant sa
volonté aussi il faut resituer dans le
contexte où nana une émergence du
secteur de l'art contemporain avec des
critères avec d'étonnants de l'art
contemporain qui sont qui était
notamment au frac avec une politique
assez volontariste et elithis d'ailleurs
marcel tv à l'époque par les d'élitisme
au populaire il y avait le musée léon
dierx avec françois cheval qui arrivait
avec des grands noms de l'art
contemporain extérieur et en face il ya
william de carrie à l'artothèque et nuit
voila voila on passera à côté en tout
cas en face à face vraiment dans une
confrontation
williams arrive et puis va exposer des
artistes un peu traditionnelle qu'ils
font voilà des artistes qui sont un peu
en marge et qui font qu'ils font une
peinture qui ne se revendique pas ni
conceptuel ni dans les canons
esthétiques contemporain et c'était
aussi une volonté de dire allons allons
imaginer de quelle manière on va fonder
l'histoire de l'art à la réunion écrite
par les réunionnais et non pas sur des
canons extérieur donc c'est on est
vraiment sûr je vous adresse jean-michel
et la sarcelle suiveurs j'allais voir
comment il est jean michel bonsoir
alors jean michel bonsoir oui bon
racontez nous comment va se passer la
première fois d'autres ont en outre
rencontra conscient qu'il ya proposa aux
de bain d'être son modèle raconte à nous
ça vous rappelle
haïku d'un drap il est là jean-michel
entend moins bon jeu michel nous
continuent quand on voit intervenir ou
intervient rouler à l'antenne le
technicien quand il est là donc quand il
a envie de causer aux causes d'accord ok
parmi ces paroles entendues alors en
dehors donc des t2 cave est ce qu on
avait d'autres
d'autres thèmes que william y est mais
bien du monde y est tout ce qu'il ya
autour du monde
mais malgré tout ça avec tellement
longtemps et pas vu son cadre donc du
coup ça mais c'est vrai non plus si bon
dieu mais cette part de dire cette envie
de pain des petits bons duels étaient
vraiment en lui ça c'est pas seulement
les petits pondent il appelle d'ailleurs
fait hommage
laon de de la messe donc on a mis sur la
table avec des fleurs du jardin et le
dernier
enfin une tête qui l'avait fait avec un
artiste qui là qu'il a un peu porté
depuis le début niclin crise a
effectivement week riner qui a weekend
au site admiratif j'ai pas revu depuis
longtemps d'ailleurs cris linge et si je
revis faisons grève de la faim l'année
dernière devant le conseil général à
l'occasion d'un préfecture d'années
travaillées alors jean michel est là
parce que ça coupe le réseau été mauvais
dans weeds habite jean michel notamment
jean-michel bon on n'a vraiment pas de
chance à ses mains de mme auger un miro
moins bon et c'est de bouger alors on
essaie de bouger parce qu apparemment
très mauvais alors encore un petit peu
de temps pauvre alors 2e dans quelques
jours et vous dis alors on va pas aller
aussi bas on a parlé du cas précis du
pays tant convoité mais la langue la
langue la langue créole
voilà ça c'est quelque chose aussi qu'il
était qu'il était défendre mais veut
dire peut-être il connaît plus le
peintre que le défenseur banon mais
c'était en plus ce n'est pas une époque
où tu es évident de dire par exemple de
faire des textes en créole de ferries
habitations en créole donc c'était très
intéressant c'était vraiment un moment
où ça a émergé même si noter quand même
sourit éric boyer et qu'on avait
franchement une commande hier une
mondiale une politique très favorables à
la chasse identité bien sûr c'était
quand même progressif
parce que je voyais quand même deux
premiers avant d'y avoir mis maloya non
la mairie de saint-denis déjà comité
régional et avoir la démarche est à
l'abri d'une efficacité pas mais oui
demi ne voulait pas être quelque chose
de particulier will non mais je sais que
ce travail de militantisme à la fois aux
toits de l'art et autour de la réunion
c'est quelque chose qu'il a beaucoup
porté en radio c'est parce que william a
été un excellent animateur de radio
c'est quelque chose qu'il avait fait un
peu déjà sur une autre radio mais
vraiment ce pari d'abord même si c'était
sur l impôt à paris d'avoir une émission
toutes les semaines autour des arts
plastiques de la taxe était mardi soir 1
c'est un sacré pari de se dire on fait
une émission tous les soirs autres arts
plastiques et william avaient en plus
qu'à passer de cet été lui qui
maîtrisait totalement le choix des
invités
donc moi je le découvrirai deux jours
avant dix à intel qui vient mais moi
j'étais le candidat et c'était lui qui
menait le jeu et ça consistait justement
à a essayé d'amener les gens plus loin
que l'interview confortable et il était
assez redoutable ça leur en parler de
terrasses moi j'ai le souvenir d'une
émission de radio où il deux émissions
de radio une avec tyrosse et william et
une autre avec marcel t'avais et william
et là on voyait bien que le s'était pas
que des partis pris picturaux ou
artistique qui les opposait les deux ans
face à face en tant que l'individu à un
moment tant qu'animateur fallait gérer
les affaires
alors justement comment comment
réagissent et l'élite va dire ça comme
ça
phase 1
et qui propose des choses qui sortent
qui convoque en rupture avec ce stosur
va l'habitude de voir comment agissent
les gens à mon sens à moi de ce que moi
l'a vécue parce qu'on en maths et en
même temps assez jeune mais de ce qu'on
a pu analyser aussi après puisque l'été
voilà pencher là dessus quand même pas
mal ça a été vraiment un séisme en tout
cas c'est ce que me l'a ressenti c'est à
dire exposés côte à côte des pilons et
de l'art contemporain exposées dans les
lieux consacrés à l'art contemporain des
artistes qui font des peintures de
cheval etc
c'était vraiment secoué sur un piédestal
et sp2 d'acquis et de et de deux
postulats et donc c'était des séismes
à mon sens assez fort antoine vignau il
faut replacer dans le contexte croit ce
que patriciens commencer un fer avec
eric boyer sa politique culturelle eric
boyer a été le premier le seul
d'ailleurs à faire des assises des arts
plastiques
on le croirait pas mais c'est vrai on y
était donc il y avait aussi une
génération qui vraiment prenez place sur
la scène avec jacques betty réponse est
rare françois girault la bateau et qu'on
était vraiment soutenu aussi très
fortement par deux d'un côté la ville de
samy aussi et faut pas oublier que les
artistes que je viens de citer ont fondé
ensuite une association qui s'appelait
je mens arts plastiques et ça participe
est un peu de toute cette énergie qui
avait c'était c'est quand même un moment
historique assez rare où il y a
les volontés politiques les volontés du
terrain et le public aussi qui vont dans
le même sens un dur est peut-être 4,5 en
mai mais c'est assez exceptionnel tant
par les maris moto oui par rapport à ça
en fait bon je m'en plastique vous voyez
tout ça c'était saint denis et saint
denis un public particulier
bann moun des traçages à tous mais enfin
décoller qu'avec homme d'une grande
culture plastique non l'important de
saint leu c'est cet oubli dit c'est que
quand williams a pas de travail c'est
lui travaillait à lui avec françois
hebel communistes occupent seuls la
ville des communistes marie hoareau
mario et puis toute la suite à quoi tu
as tout puisque mario tessier ça mais il
faut vraiment là et donc de tout le
match et toute la politique autour de ça
et il fait que la la de la créer un
espace on verra extrêmement favorable y
compris d'accueil de machin de diffusion
et d'éducation on veut dire et populaire
et c'est très intéressant avec ce que
vous avez c'est un le par appartements
ou des choses comme ça man de monde qui
vient là t'es pas de ban ki moon au
départ formés éduqués en arts plastiques
et donc du coup la vella à la fois un
travail éducation extrêmement intense
mais celle du travail des impôts en même
temps français du panel proposé propose
en puissance marcos pas band au monde
bam bam bam bam boum tous les jours dans
nos rapports émis croix dans la
continuité s'était fait comme dans la
redoutait qu'avant et s'est mutilé pas
pour rien que que si la fin que williams
mais pour le président de l'uda il peut
paraître étrange que ça quand on me l'a
dit le prof on se voyait un peu moins
érudits oui non il ya une cohérence elle
qui se dit cohérent des faits de
cohérent ou des parodies mais bien
préparé dans les derniers bizarre mais
n'ont pas du tout les cohérent il
parfaitement cohérent papa de son
travail
déplacer la question du beau du laid de
l'esthétique des productions des machins
des des canons des choses légitime et
des choses pas lisse mais les la halle
et dans le même match à le prendre la
présidence de l'ue dans la continuité de
travail de l'artothèque de ce qui était
fait les radios et et du sua agissements
de la populaire pas sur le montant des
têtes qu'apple la populaire et de la
pauvre comme à parenty rémy croire que
si le départ quand les domaines connus
que ça prend président mesdames du
caribou et fils belle et très clair aux
affaires alors jean-michel et là
apparemment 10 passes vieux jeu michel
bonsoir
jean-michel la question de la main il
passa au talent est là c'était race tour
à palau la première fois que vous la
rendre compte bien qu'il ya proposa donc
d'être sans son modèle pour une bonne
tête caf
par contre nous ça hier donc vous frisez
beaucoup du stop la route
en fait c'est comme ça ma rencontre
monsieur willy et alors il a proposé aux
données le modèle ben non mais en fait c
[Musique]
est ensuite perdu jamais décidément on
n'a vraiment pas de chance le monsieur
réalisé par nicole d'accord ok ok mais
alors eu ou là où l'afrique quand vous
de l'an pendant longtemps est ce que au
point de vue artistique est ce qu'il
apporte à bout des choses d'avoir
fréquenté williams ah bah oui monsieur
on va fabriquer ou dire mais trop c'est
quand même jeu mais chez faure michel
faure mickey un vicaire jean michel
c'est antoine comme il n'a pas d'antoine
ça va oui désolé votre émotion désolée
elle va rater le moins bon en tous les
cas ce que lui voulait dire à eau
puisque on connaît pas à florence
si donc la nièce de william que les la
côté de nous elle a très envie de
rencontrer parce que là parce que la
parata ou la semaine dernière donc me
fais de la commission pour vous pouvez
donc au camp du sort des vingt sept
membres ont pas contactés coût d'un coup
de merci encore à tous les cadavres
étaient venus même s'il ya des choses
qu'on peut pas dire
bompas n'y comprends l'émotion aussi
s'est faite aux femmes
la même source a dit à l'ats ni pourquoi
aller à quoi la même
il y en a tellement pas nous d'accord ok
merci jean michel numéro points de
contact d'accord bonne soirée
on va aller à gaza d'où deux minutes
mama eux obligés de dire un truc cité le
20 décembre
alors ça ça n'a fait qu'il supportait
pas au lieu de 20 décembre c'était pas
ça la mise en esclavage et et la révolte
des esclaves de saint-leu
c'était en fait qu'à l'entraînement
libre et ça fait la famille s'était
certes oui bien sûr mais les tout colis
a fait à piton rouge tous allez dire ça
mais claire bien sûr sonorisation sur
saint leu il faut pas oublier qu'ils
avaient aussi arsenic alors il avait ses
ces rapports
sophie sophie reparle de tout ce qui est
vraiment c'était sa base arrière un
petit peu il a fait des expos
collectives avec d'autres artistes il en
a fait énormément seul aussi et ça
complétait un peu tout travail de
proximité qui faisait sur saint leu et
d'ailleurs on salue ce fille qui doit
bien sûr écouté et nous reste 40
secondes sur quelque chose à dire et à
poster budé malheureusement machart
excuses remercier toutes les personnes
qui ont été là pour nous au nom de la
famille zitte et
que ce soit les officiels la presse tout
ce qui a été réveillé pour 30 ans et
dernière chose vous étudiez pas merci
c'était pas ça en dirait qu'ils mis en
cause et là on l'avait retenu la leçon
et on sera rasée à la libération ce
râteau dieu la libération merci florence
merci patrice abollivier merci antoine
merci papa merci dominique louis
n'aurait pu pourra pas faire en 3e mais
malheureusement nous ne communiquerons
toute l'antenne de mise voilà ça besoin
[Musique]